alors de nous et c'est une très belle
histoire et puis je crois c'est d'abord
avant tout une histoire d'amour
simplement parce qu'elles contiennent
des animaux 10 en france et une chanson
de chacun diffèrent depuis très
longtemps j'ai jamais eu l'occasion
jusqu'à maintenant de chanter les
animaux et en plus d'avoir l'occasion de
chanter avec des enfants ce que j'ai
trouvé son merveilleux et puis je trouve
que pour moi le plus beau la plus belle
des récompenses et lorsque je chante ça
le matin les deux fils aient une vie on
le prend 10 min c'est incroyable
chaque fois que nous partons en vacances
on prend toujours trop d'affaires mais
cette fois ci pas question même si mes
enfants me disent
on a discuté
je veux dire que pendant toute mon
enfance j'ai eu des animaux
j'ai commencé par avoir des cochons dan
évidemment je vais voter dans la poche
puis un jour je m'était arrivé une
aventure assez drôle d'ailleurs un jour
j'avais un cochon dingue tu es dans ma
cuisine chez moi ils mangé mon jeu sans
arrêt voulait jamais sortir de sa boîte
et alors c'était vraiment c'était plus
un cauchemar c'était un hippopotame
j'étais très inquiète
puis un matin je me suis réveillé
j'étais petite fille je me rappelle très
bien
j'aidais ma mère non mais il a quatre
oreilles parce que je me suis aperçu que
c'était une femelle 4 et des petits et
puis dans la nuit va ma foi alors au
lieu d'avoir un cochon d'inde avec
quatre cochons d'inde ce qui évidemment
va être très vite y en avait partout
j'ai donné à les petits camarades mais
je veux dire que pour moi c'était une
aventure assez assez merveilleux c'est
incroyable
chaque fois que nous partons en vacances
on compte toujours trop d'affaires mais
cette fois ci pas question même si mes
enfants me disent
nina simone
on a décidé
c'est fait
qu'elle regarde
le maire
oprah
banda
ja
olé
essai
m
le pas
avant le double il guérit va mieux
o le chignon qui le voulaient sud ou
alors moi j'ai deux chiens je trouve
qu'ils sont vraiment extraordinaire
d'avoir celui là lui seïf c'est un
berger des pyrénées
j'ai été le chercher dans ces montagnes
natales il est très très gentil et puis
lui cet homme alors il lui il est un peu
plus vieux il a six ans je veux dire que
ces deux chiens et vient les qualités
qu'on leur trouve et arrêtent les
qualités qu'on peut leur trouver c'est
la fidélité d'abord parce que c'est un
chien qui sont à l'europe pour ça le
coût de ces affections le côté défense
parce que c'est des chiens qui vraiment
vous protège vous sentez totalement en
sécurité quand vous êtes avec eux je
crois que si les incorruptibles tous les
2-3 que si un jour pour une raison ou
pour une autre vous arrivez quelque
chose ni l'un ni l'autre ne s'en
remettraient maintenant de là à dire
qu'il ferait 200 km pour venir montant
de jantes et ça je ne sais pas je
n'aurai jamais posé la question mais je
ne sais pas ce sont les fanatiques ou
pas
et un chien frétille déjà
lannion
voeckler
dix d'entre elles ont
ok
c'est là
nos yeux
enfin ça ira là on se serrera
on coupe le jour de la plate
pour ceux qu'on aime
enfin la pluie
comment
évidemment il m'est arrivé l'état d'
aventure avec eux et puis tom may fois
et bien tom étant donné qu'il a été
vraiment élevé avec nous comme un chien
comme un petit caniche dans ces
merveilleux parce que maintenant il est
habitué à nous il fait attention à tout
quand je vais me balader avec lui
supporte pas comme suivi je veux dire
que je suis suis très fier sont en
sécurité quand je suis avec 8 alors lui
c'est pas du tout le même caractère
c'est un indépendant total il a sans
territoire il y reste que alors la
société en a vraiment absolument rien à
faire je crois que s'embrasser lettres
une libellule
c'est vrai comme dans le film de yann
film de walt disney je crois que c'est
peter pan d'ailleurs où il ya un chien
qui veut voler et lui quand il voit des
oiseaux il courra pas il veut voler
vraiment il fait comme ça et tout ici
crois quoi comme libellules c'est pas
léger m'enfin bon pourquoi pas après
tout
qui ne sait plus
hélas
qui nous
sedan
on peut
en se servant
non
voire plus
en bas
c'est là
enfin ça ira
va chercher ton papa
là